hình thường đường hủ chang, thành phố hiện có một trong đối với bây giờ ăn đã được chấp hận chủ trường đầu tư,
phọng giáu chủ đầu tư, với tổng quy mô khoảng 1,5 hành yển cả nổ,
tổng vô đầu tư khoảng 2,5 yển, năng trập tì đồng.
Trong đó, có bao môi dưới hoàn đầu tư đã khởi công sây dưỡng,
đang thi công, mới quy mô đầu tư khoảng 2,5 yển cả nổ,
quy mô dự ăn giữ kiai hoàn thành sây dự ự phần thô công trên trong năm nay,
hành yển của trong 5 hảo, với khoảng 5 yển, 1 trong cân,
và môi chiến sửa đầu tư còn lại dự kiai đù đều kẹp cúc ứng ra thì trong trong năm 2020.
Nhiều đẹp nhàng tiền đồ các dự ăn,
thành phố yêu cầu áp dụng cơ trẻ là anh xanh đối với tònh bộ thu tục liên quan đến nhẹ ổ xa hội.
Các giảm ý nhất năm 2019 thử dàng dải quyết thu tục hành trính,
trong các liên vực quy hoạt đầu tư đất đài và sây dự.
thành phố yêu tiên dải quyết ngày các thu tục đối với những dự ăn đã của mất bằng sạch để kở công trong thống bây và tháng 3 năm 2020.